الآن جزء من أه
الضم الروسي الذي تعرفه أم ضم روسيا
هو تصريح الرئيس بوتين
أه أنه قال مرتين أن هذه
الأراضي الآن روسية وأنه
سيدافع عن هذه الأراضي الروسية
بكل الوسائل الممكنة والإعلام الروسي
لديه  لقد فسر أه مرارًا وتكرارًا على
أنه يعني الأسلحة النووية على وجه التحديد
كما فعل ديميتري ميدفيديف ، لذا
يبدو أن هذا يرفع المخاطر بشكل كبير ،
ما رأيك في حقيقة أن
فلاديمير بوتين يقول بشكل أساسي في
هذه المرحلة أنه إذا كان هناك إذا شعر أن
هناك هجومًا من  أه الناتو
أفترض في الأراضي الروسية التي
تضم الآن كل الدونباس
يحتفظ بالحق في استخدام الأسلحة النووية ردًا
مرة أخرى إنه غير قانوني أه ادعاء أنه
تصريح غير مسؤول ، هل
تعلمون أن قعقعة السمور النووي ليست
من النوع الذي أه  التي
نتوقع أن نسمعها من قادة أه
الدول الكبيرة مع أه بإمكانيات
أه وما يمكن أن نتوقع رؤيته
نتوقع أن يواصل الأوكرانيون
أه في المضي قدمًا
ومحاولة استعادة كل أه
الأراضي داخل
حدودهم السيادية هنا ولذا لا
أعتقد أن هذا سيتوقف
وسنواصل دعمهم في  جهودهم